Lorsque les gens apprirent qui avait la plus grosse
Des émeutes sont apparus
L'anarchie c'est mise en place
les gens n'avaient plus de raison de vivre
jusqu'au jour où Jean Michel j'calme le game arriva
il fit un discours instaurant une nouvelle question dans la tête des gens
Quel Youtuber êtes-vous ?
la vie repris sont cours
les émeutes cessèrent
Du moins jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un réponde à cette question
ok ok c'est une intro bien épique pour un quizz un peu pété quand même hein
Aujourd'hui nous sommes sur Topito.com
Voilà ya François qui a publié hier au moment où je tourne cette vidéo un quizz pour savoir quel youtuber nous sommes
Les chaînes Youtube et Youtubeurs pullulent sur Internet depuis quelques années. Et on est sûr à 59% que tu es abonné(e) à plus de 10 chaines.
Bon peut-être mais t’arrêtera d'être prétentieux ...
Et comme tu rêves tu secrètement de devenir Youtubeur de qualité, on te propose un joli quiz offrant la possibilité de savoir quelle personnalité de l'Internet tu es.
Question petit un
Attends on se croirait en cours d'histoire la
Quel est le premier site que tu visite lorsque tu te rends sur l'internet ?
Facebook, Twitter, Youtube, Skyblog, Youporn ou Topito
Twitter.
J'check s'qui ya buzzé dans la nuit, Jme renseigne et tout ! j'suis comme ça devant les dramas : "eh vasy clash le !"
Voilà.
Question 2 petit c
Comment navigues-tu sur le World Wide Web ?
Avec ta souris tel un BG
Avec ton pad comme un galérien
Avec ton pouce sale et plein d'ADN de barres de metro
Hmmm excellente question Jackson
Bon j'suis un gros beauf mais ... Avec ta souris tel un BG
OU ALORS avec le pad ça dépend c'est 1 fois sur 2
Si je vais sur le pc portable ou pas en me levant
J'raconte ma vie on s'en fou mais c'est important hein
J'veux dire à l'issue de ce quizz le monde changera putain
Bon aller aller on va aller sur la souris
Question 3 petit q
J'parle pas du tiens :D
Quel secret d’Internet souhaites-tu découvrir ?
Le moyen d'agrandir sa bite en seulement 3 semaines
Alors ça c'était le cas quand on venait de voir la bite de la sperm baleine dans la vidéo d'avant où laaa après une bonne nuit ça va mieux
Rencontrer des meufs chaudes dans ta région
bah faut juste cliquer sur les spams tout le monde sait comment faire
Trouver un remède simple contre l'acné et Ebola et que les médecins te détestent
Il m'prend par les sentiments :(
Percer la manière de gagner 3000€ par mois en restant chez toi
Bah ça faut juste faire des vidéos de merde sur youtube !
DES BARRES !
DU COUP je veux Trouver un remède simple contre l'acné et Ebola
Voilà !
4 petit f Quel est ton nombre préféré parmi cette liste non-exhaustive de 6 nombres ?
1, 2, 10, 3.14159265359
Ah c'est mon nom préféré putain
L'infini
ou l'infini+1
moi j'aime bien l'infini+1 puisse que c'est l'insolence à l'étape pure
Ah ouais machin c'est infini bah moi c'est infini +1 !
EH BAH MOI C'EST INFINI+2 !
FERME TA GUEULE FERME TA GUEULE
Infini+32
Quelle est ta position favorite ?
Debout, assise, allongée, oblique
Le 69 (c'est le sesque)
Dans le sens inverse des aiguilles d'une montre
J'avoue bien aimé la position oblique
J'dors vraiment comme ça en plus
Après j'avoue des fois j'dors dans le sens inverse des aiguilles d'une montre donc du coup j'sais pas
Pirouette, cacahuèteuh
Eh bah c'est oblique !
Question 6 partie 2 petit z
Droitier ou gaucher ?
OU CHAUVE
Gaucher j'suis gaucher on va mettre gaucher ! rpz la gauche toi mm tu c mon frr
oh nan.
Très bien j'arrête ma chaîne Youtube
Question 7 - As-tu déjà ... BRANLÉ UN POTE
même juste pour le fun au plus grand des calmes ?
MAIS TOUT LES MATINS AVANT DE FAIRE DES VIDEOS POURQUOI JSUIS EN FORME A TON AVIS ?
BAH J'BRANLE UN POTE putain ...
*les pastilles à sucer ? --> je sors*
J'me sens mal
Quelle cuisson la viande ?
Bleu, saignante, A point, bien cuite, Pas de cuisson l'ami, tu me fous ça en mode tartare
Non merci je ne mange pas de viande, en revanche je vais vous prendre des cailloux, c'est bon les cailloux
J'ai des doutes sur cette dernière blague mais celle d'avant était pas mal
Question 9 - Manger une banane par le haut ou pas le bas ?
Par le haut ... ou pas le bas
ça revient au même finalement
t'étais entrain de m'entourlouper fdp François
Par le haut bien sur c'est bien plus simple
chapitre 4 question 10 petit z
Quelle ?
On en ... on en a marre de cette blague hein
Quelle poutre mérite le plus d’abonnés ?
Oh putain.
La poutre mélomane sur les heures de pointe
La poutre monoxyde de carbone
La poutre agissant durablement sur l'environnement
La poutre alourdie par le poids des remords
La poutre qui a vu ses actions grimpées en Bourse de 4%
ou la poutre dérangée par son voisin au petit matin car ce fumier fait des travaux chez lui
CELLE LA !
CELLE LA
CE FILS DE PUTE QUI FAIT DES TRAVAUX LA DE TEMPS EN TEMPS LE MATIN
OK ON Se calmeu
C'est l'heure des résultats quel youtuber vais-je être ?
Tu est Cypri1
*omg comment on a pas vu ça*
Je suis juste schizophrène depuis tout ce temps
Il n'y avait en fait qu'une seule personne sur le canapé de Cyprien Gaming ?
Ah par contre je suis celui qui a le plus d'abonné en France ça c'est clair
La avec toutes les chaînes jeuh
Tu es quelqu’un de particulièrement riche, friqué et possédant une somme d’argent allant bien au-delà de 16€
C'est vrai.
De plus, tu es célèbre dans le monde entier, plus que Brad Pitt et Obama, et tout le monde veut ton corps afin de le palper.
Régulièrement les gens palpent Cyprien c'est vrai
Chez toi, tu détiens deux fusées, un hélicoptère et une machine à coudre
J'suis pas sur pour la machine à coudre
Bon et bah voilà c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur ce quizz complétement teubé merci François
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu
On a bien rigolé ! euh
Euh ça va plus ça va plus j'ai plus de question sans réponse dans ma tête